Transcriber: Sara Ozturk
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Herkese merhaba.
Çocuk yetiştirenler olarak ebeveynler
ve tüm bakım verenler,
hepimizin çocuklara dair hayalleri var,
beklentileri var.
Böyle yıllar sonrasına dair belki bazı
resimler geliyor gözümüzün önüne.
Çok mutlular, çok iyi hissediyorlar
ve belki bugün yaptığımız her şeyi
bu hedef üzerine kurguluyoruz.
Onların ileride mutlu birer birey
olmaları için ne yapabilirim?
Ama acaba bu beklentinin içinde
çok da kolay olmayan,
belki gerçekle yüzde yüz
örtüşmeyen bir yerler olabilir mi?
Şöyle bir bakalım kendi hayatımıza.
Bunca yıllık hayatımız içinde
tamamen iyi hissettiğimiz,
mutsuzluğun köşesinden bile geçmediğimiz
tek bir 24 saat var mı?
O yüzden acaba sorun beklentimiz
ile başlıyor olabilir mi?
Bu beklenti bize öğretilmiş ama gerçek
olmayan bir beklenti olabilir mi?
Ve bir de şurdan bakalım.
Tamamen mutlu olmak mümkün mü acaba?
Bu hayatın içinde tamamen
iyi hissetmek mümkün mü?
Hayat böyle bir şey mi acaba?
Şimdi buradan baktığınız zaman hemen
belki şuna gelmek gerekiyor.
Bizim sinir sistemimiz.
Kuruluş amacı olarak tamamen
mutlu olmak üzerine değil,
kendini güvende hissetmek
üzerine kurgulu bir sistem,
altyapısı böyle.
Hissettiğimiz her şey, vücudumuzun,
beynimizin, sinir sistemimizin
verdiği her sinyal tamamen
mutlu olmamız için değil.
Nerede güvende ve nerede güvensiz
hissettiğimizi iyi anlayabilmemiz için.
O zaman acaba nörolojik, biyolojik alt
yapımıza ters bir hedefle tüm hayatımızı
yaşıyor ve bununla beraber de yine bunun
üzerine kurulu bir ebeveynlik ile
çocuk yetiştiriyor olabilir miyiz?
Ebeveynlik hiç kolay değil bu zamanlarda.
Çok önemli bir yeri
yakaladığımızı hissediyorum.
Ebeveynlik çok uzun yıllardır
çok davranış odaklı.
Ama bakın deminden beri biz
hislerden bahsediyoruz.
Ve ana temelimizin, ana altyapımızın
hisler üzerine olduğunu konuşuyoruz.
Ama bizi yetiştiren büyükler de
ve belki de biz de
davranış odaklı olabilir miyiz?
Evet, son yıllarda doğal ebeveynlik,
duyarlı ebeveynlik,
bağlanma odaklı ebeveynlik gibi
daha farklı perspektifler de duyuyoruz.
Ama ilk aklımıza gelen belki de bu
çocuk nasıl davranıyor
ve bu durumda ben nasıl davranmalıyım?
Ödev yapmıyor.
Nasıl yaptırtabilirim?
Çok ağlıyor.
Bu ağlamaları nasıl susturabilirim?
İstemediği olduğunda hemen bağırıyor
bu bağırmaların sonunu getirmek için
ne demem gerekiyor?
Bakın bu cümlelerin
hepsinin içinde davranış var.
O sırada o ne hissediyor
ve neden böyle davranıyor?
Pek de hemen öyle hızlı gelen
bir düşünce olmuyor bize.
Evet, böyle bir altyapıdan geliyoruz
ve bu bizi çok sıkıştırıyor belki de.
Ayrıca ikincisi büyük bir bilgi
dağına maruz kalıyoruz.
Eskiden belki de daha akademik bilgide
kalan ebeveynlik kavramı
ve doğru ebeveynlik üzerine şu an
ebeveynlere kadar ulaşan birçok bilgi var
ve birçok uzman var.
Bununla beraber de doğru ebeveynliği
birçok kaynaktan
okuyabiliyoruz, izleyebiliyoruz.
Okuyup izleyebiliyorsam
ve ne yapacağımı biliyorsam
çok da iyi uyguluyor olmam gerekiyor.
Puanlar önce bana bu sayede de
yetişen mutlu çocuğuma.
Ama işte işler o kadar kolay olmuyor.
Ve belki de burada da sıkışıyoruz.
Ciddi bir mükemmeliyet baskısı altındayız.
Çocuğumuz eğer mutsuz ise
biz bir şeyleri yanlış yapıyor olmalıyız.
Bütün bunların içinden şöyle
sıyrılmak istiyorum.
Bunlar belki de fark etmemiz
ve değiştirmemiz gereken yerler.
Çünkü aslında ne dedik sinir sistemi
güvende hissetmek üzerine kurgulu
ve en güvende hissettiğim yer belki de
en mutlu olduğum yer olmayabilir.
Mutlu olmama hakkına sahip
olduğum yerdir belki.
Ve bu da biz ebeveynlerin,
çocuklara bakım verenlerin
çocukların karanlık yüzlerini
kabul etmesiyle başlıyor.
O olumsuz kolladığımız duyguları,
evet olumsuz hissedebilirsin
ama bu senin bir parçan ve normal diyerek
gerçek bir kabulle
sıcacık bir battaniye gibi
sarıp sarmalamamızla belki başlıyor.
Onların iyi hissetmediği yerleri
davranışlarından öte
görebilmemiz anlayabilmemiz,
yaşamalarına belki de
izin vermemizle başlıyor.
Ve bütün bunları da harika yapsak
evet, belki duyguları da çok iyi görüyorum
ve çok da iyi de kapsıyorum o anlarda.
Yine de evet,
çocuk oldukları için ağlarlar.
Ve evet, yine çocuk oldukları
için bağırırlar.
Bazen yanlış davranırlar.
Ve bazen saklanırlar.
Ama paylaşmak da istemeyebilirler,
iyi hissetmeyebilirler.
Her insan ve her memeli gibi.
Olduğu gibi olmalarına izin
verebilir miyiz acaba?
İşte bu halleriyle beraber onların
her halini sevebilir miyiz?
Ve ilerde kendilerini güvende hisseden
bir birey olmaları için,
kendilerini her halleriyle sevmeleri için
bugün onların her duygusunu sevmeyi
başarabilir miyiz acaba?
Hatırlıyorum,
çocukken hep aynı kreşe giderdim.
Başladım üç yaşında, beş yaşına kadar
aynı kreş, anaokulu devam ettim.
Hatırlıyorum, çok mutsuzdum.
Gerçekten çok mutsuzdum,
anılardan çok duyguları, kokuları,
bazı böyle görüntüleri hatırlıyorum.
Hiç iyi hissettiğim bir gün
olmadı diyebilirim.
Ya da en azından şu an
bana kalan duygusu bu.
Ve bir gün anneme sordum.
Okulun ilk günü nasıldım?
O kapıdan nasıl girdim?
Seni bırakmadığım oldu mu?
Ya da sonraki günlerde bugün mutsuzdum
ve okula gitmek istemiyorum dediğim
hangi günler vardı?
Ve annem şu cevabı verdi:
“Hiç öyle bir şey olmadı Melis.
İlk gün girdin, hiçbir şey demedin
ve ondan sonra her gün o kapıdan girdin
ve her şey yolundaydı.
Her şey gerçekten yolunda mıydı?
İşte ben bugün size yıllarca ağlayamamış,
yıllarca mutsuz olma hakkına
hiç sahip olmamış,
yıllarca bu duyguları
dile getirmekten korkmuş
ve bu duyguları hissederken
hiç güvende hissetmemiş
bir çocuğun
yetişkin halinden sesleniyorum.
Böyle olmak hiç kolay değildi ve böyle
çocuklar yetiştirmemek için
kendilerini daha güvenli
hissetmeleri için acaba ne yapabiliriz?
İşte o karanlık yüzü sevmekle
başlayabiliriz.
Çünkü o karanlık yüz bir canavar değil.
Bizim atmamız gereken içimizden
karanlık bir parça değil.
O bizim kim olduğumuz.
O madalyonun diğer yüzü.
O biziz.
Ve evet, böyle baktığımız zaman biz
bunları ne kadar kabul etmek istesek de
nerede buluyoruz kendimizi?
Hayır, çocukların olumsuz hallerine
hiç tahammülümüz yok.
O hallerini istemiyoruz,
görmek istemiyoruz.
Onlar yaşasın istemiyoruz.
Acı çekmesinler, üzülmesinler,
kırılmasınlar.
Evet, elbette ki çok büyük
acılar çekmesinler.
Elbette ki hayatlarının
büyük bir parçası mutluluk olsun.
Ama bu mutluluğun acaba kaynağı,
hep mutlu olma baskısı ile
büyümemekten geçiyor olabilir mi?
Çünkü biz bu baskıyla büyüdük.
Dile gelebilen çocuklar mıydık?
Dile gelmenin mücadele gerektirdiğini
öğrenenlerden miydik yoksa?
Onlar dile gelmek için,
kendileri olmak için
bu mücadeleyi vermek zorunda olmasınlar.
Oysaki çok ayar veriyoruz,
çok düzeltiyoruz.
Düştün, acıdı, geçecek
ama buna da üzülmez.
Bunda korkacak hiçbir şey yok.
Hep iyi hissetmelisin.
Ama biz enfes bir heykel tasarlamıyoruz.
Bunun farkında olmamız çok önemli.
İnsan olmak demek bir heykel inşa
etmek değil, insan olmak demek
gerçekten her parçamla iyi hissettiğim,
iyi hissetmediğim, doğru davrandığım,
yanlış davrandığım birçok anın
beraber kabulü olabilir mi?
Çünkü insan olmak buysa
doğama ters aslında büyütülüyor
ve doğama ters olmam
gerektiği öğretilmesinin
nasıl bir faydası olabilir bana?
Bu zinciri kırmamız gerekiyor.
Bu zinciri çünkü ancak kırarsak o zaman
her parçasını seven bireyler
yetiştirmiş oluyoruz.
Ve bu zinciri kırmak da en
başta kabulle başlıyor.
Onların ve kendimizin yaralarını
ve berelerini,
iyi hissetmediği her anlarını,
minicikken utanmalarını,
Çok öfkelenmelerini minicik bir şeye.
Evet,
bazen kaygılı olmalarını,
bazen endişeli olmalarını,
bazen dünyanın en bağımsız çocuğuyken
bir anda anne, baba olmalarını.
Evet, bazen de
olumsuz tecrübeler yaşamalarını.
Her şey yolunda gitmiyor.
O arkadaş seninle oynamadı.
Bugün hastayım
ve her gün gördüğün anne,
baba değilim belki.
Bunları gerçekten kabul veriyor muyuz?
Bunlara izin veriyor muyuz?
Veya en önemlisi iyi hissetmemelerine bu
izni verirken bu anları onlarla beraber
gerçekten yaşıyor muyuz?
Evet, olumsuz duyguları hiçbir
zaman sevmeyeceksin
ama onlarda güvendesin.
Çünkü sana bunu öğrettim.
Çünkü daha minicik bir bebektin
ve ben o anlarda hep yanındaydım.
Sinir sistemimin o anları bir düşman gibi
değil, duyulması gereken bir dost gibi
kodlaması için buna ihtiyacım var.
Çünkü ancak çocukken bunu aldığımda
sonra böyle bir yetişkine büyüyorum.
Önce bakım verenlerimle
yapıyorum bunu, iyi hissetmiyorum
ama burada sesi, iyi hissetmiyorum
ama sarıldı bana, iyi hissetmiyorum
ve hüngür hüngür ağlıyorum
ve izin veriyor.
Ama bir an göz göze gelsek
o bir saniye içinde
onun yüzünden bu ağladığım her damlanın
dinlendiğini görüyorum.
Bir saniye bile onun yüzüne baksam onun
beni ne kadar iyi anladığını
ve yanımda olduğunu hissediyorum.
Ağlamamam ve iyi olmam
değil amaç, kendim olmam.
Ebeveynlerim bana bunu öğretti
ve bu sayede ben büyüdükçe
ve geliştikçe artık bu zor anlarla
ve bu zor duygularla baş edebiliyorum.
Hep mutlu olmamam gerektiğini biliyorum.
Mutlu olmak istiyorum ama mutsuz olduğumda
da o anları geçebiliyorum.
Çünkü gerçek güven hissi tamamen mutlu
olmaktan değil, kendim olmaktan geçiyor.
O yüzden belki de hedefi işte kendi olan
çocuklar büyütmeye koymalıyız.
Olumsuz hissetmemeye değil,
olumsuz hislerin içinden
geçmeye koymalıyız.
Hiç zorlanmasınlar,
hiç ama hiç o zorluk hissini
kalplerinde hissetmesinlere değil,
“Zorlukları beraber yaşayabiliriz
ve geçebiliriz.”
deyip dayanıklılık geliştirmelerine
belki koymalıyız.
Bütün bunların sonunda
karanlık yüzlerini sevmeliyiz.
Hep aydınlık yok çünkü.
Her gecenin gündüzü,
ve her gündüzün bir gecesi var
ve karanlık olmadan ışığı da göremiyoruz.
Hepsi bir bütün.
Evet, bugünden itibaren bu zinciri kırıp
o karanlık yüzlerini sevmeyi deneyelim.
Karanlık yüzlerini seven, her halleriyle
kendi olan ve bu sayede duygularıyla
baş edebilen ve daha dayanıklı
çocuklar yetiştirelim.
Ve inanıyorum ki
ancak o zaman dünya da insanlık da
gerçekten çok daha güzel olacak.